now we have an extensive discussion with
our European colleagues here on how we
do address the root causes of the piracy
so that the relapse is not possible in
the near future and other benefits we
have been shown today here in this
mothership the real information have the
real picture of the piracy phenomena on
how it's affecting and working and how
these forces are working on addressing
that issue
Europe relies on the trade that goes
through the bab-el-mandeb Straits 5,000
ships a month pass through that I should
think 80% of that on their way north
through there and up to Suez is going to
conduct trade with Europe if we don't
have confidence in that route then all
of a sudden one of our key interests is
affected we need to keep the pressure on
the pirates we protect World Food
Program ships we deter and suppress
piracy we protect vulnerable shipping
and we contribute to the monitoring of
fishing activities of the coast of
Somalia
it looks like that the counter-piracy
over the last years is a successful
approach by the international community
operating over here but it is a
reversible thing and if we go away it
will come back and until Somalia is not
able to control their own Khosla a
coastline with her own Coast Guard and
their own ships I think the
international community has to be
committed
here in this area
today it was an eye-opening experience
for us and it was a privilege and honor
to be here and have all this information